(upbeat music)
- Bienvenidos, and welcome
to the Peabody museum collections.
We're here surveying the national birds
of Latin American countries.
I am holding here Golden eagle.
This is a specimen from the United States,
but this species also
found in Northern Mexico,
in Baja, California, and Northern States.
And it's a declining,
therefore it's on the list of
threatened species in Mexico.
You can actually see
that, unlike Bald eagle,
the Golden eagle and members of this genus
have feathered tarsus,
the lower part of the leg,
just up to the toes.
So this feathering is unique
and I have here another raptor,
this one is a national bird for Panama.
So I'm gonna try to gently lift it.
This is a Harpy eagle
and it's a juvenile bird,
adult would have a big
black band on the breast.
And if we can maybe focus quickly on the
talons of this bird, this
is really the largest
and most powerful eagle in the America
and the world.
And these talents here,
the claws are the size of
grizzly bears claws.
This bird is pretty widely
distributed in Panama,
it's mostly found in the Darien
region in the Eastern Panama
against the border of Colombia,
because it requires large
swaths of a mature forest
One pair can occupy a territory
of 25 kilometers squared,
so, this kind of forester are harder
and harder for these birds to find,
and they have declined
and even disappeared
from parts of their range.
But in Panama, it's still
a reliable bird to see.
Then I wanted to show you the spectacular
Resplendent quetzal, at
here's a male from Honduras,
but this bird is a
national bird of Guatemala.
And what you see here as a,
what looks like a tail is
in fact, upper tail covered.
So these are feathers
that come over the tail
and the tail is this black and white,
much shorter set of feathers.
So this is very long tail let's call it,
is in the birds from North of the range.
But if you go to countries
like Costa Rica or Panama,
where this species riches with it ranges,
you see that the tails are much
shorter in this population.
One other thing I wanted to point out
that on this male here,
the red of his belly is rather faded.
And this actually what
happens when the bird
is on the exhibit for a long time,
this bird is mounted for
display in for galleries
and has glass eyes, and
clearly was exposed to light
quite a bit.
So this is a challenge we
face when we exhibit specimens
in the galleries, but here's
a fresh specimen, a female,
and you can actually see how
much brighter red her belly is,
but you can also notice that
structural color is those
that don't depend on pigments don't fade.
And in this case, it's bright green,
beautiful preserved color.
Then, here is a Toucan, this
is actually a sulfuratus,
the Keel-billed toucan in English
and in the country of Belize,
this is a national bird
and they sometimes called
it just Billed bird.
And that's obviously because
of this massive bill,
which in life would be brightly,
rainbow colored with green,
red orange, unfortunately in
specimens in a collection,
these colors are gone.
So we usually, when we collect these
record colors with photography
or just the description in the field.
And here we have a specimen
of a Turquoise-browed motmot
and this bird was chosen as a
national bird by two countries
by El Salvador, I believe
where it's called Torogoz
and in Nicaragua where
it's called Guardabarranco
in both cases, these
names make a lot of sense.
In one case, Torogoz it's
from (indistinct) name,
and it's resembles the
triple called at Brit
make in some situations like
alarming when they alarm
and the other name,
Guardabarranco simply refers,
it translates into guard of
the Barranca or the Valley.
They nest in cliffs, excavate
burrows in banks of earth,
and sometimes can nest colonially.
And what other interesting
feature here you see
that the tail has the part
of the, of the vein missing.
This is actually a natural phenomenon,
the tail ends with these beautiful
iridescent blue spatulas.
And these are the only
two central feathers
that do this trick.
These naturally fall off the bird
doesn't have to pluck this,
but feather starts with a complete vein.
So that's kind of an
interesting phenomenon
only found in motmot.
And yeah, this is a bird
that normally it will be
hard to find in the forest.
Most of any species of
motmots can be easily heard,
but not easily seen because
they sit motion less
and they are sit and wait predators
somewhere in the forest under story.
But this particular Toucan, motmot sorry
is actually quite common
and can be found in more open habitats.
I saw my first bird in
the Yucatan of Mexico,
and it was sitting on a
wire of the power line.
So, can be found even
in urban suburban areas.
Then we have this spectacular Mccall.
This bird is a national bird of Honduras.
Scarlet macaw has a wide range,
it's found not only in central America,
but also in South America,
but has declined and pet
trade and habitat loss
is some of the reasons.
They require large cavities for nesting
and what usually you see flying in pairs
or small family groups,
as luckily it's still
relatively easy to find
in most of the countries,
but in Honduras where
it's a national bird,
it's now restricted to Mosquito region.
And finally rather drop bird,
this is a national bird of Costa Rica,
and it has a rather interesting name
(speaking in foreign language).
It's what I call the
nightingale phenomenon,
where a drab looking bird like in Europe,
the Nightingales cause a spectacular song
and it's really valued for the song,
but also it often sings at night.
So it's often at the time when people
are on a date and it's kind
of a romantic scene, nice
song, nice conditions.
And farmers rely on the fact
that the birds start singing
very intensively at the beginning of rains
when rainy season begins.
So it's a good time to start planting.
(upbeat music)